hello and welcome to this video blitz
game on HS yep
this will be this is played like right
before it gets released basically I did
not I made a I made simply made a
mistake there with my video recording
and I only had two videos for this um
Monday March 18th and so I record a
third video and then upload the three so
um I just complete this
three video bunch okay yeah I played
them that it's not really great at what
I did him this is just a rather young
and
inspiring I have to say what I did an
aspiring queen pawn opening this is
really not very young very great
it looks like blackest yeah like it's
already taking over the initiative a
little bit Bishop f5 rook c8 I've got
I'm a little bit
yeah the C file he is not really
great yeah what do I do him it will
definitely get in some woodsy age if I
play Knight c3 zone I'm sort of
threatening d5 it's not great relief was
that I can USB disconnect
oops but my mouse is still working
but a traditional cable based one oops
I tried Wireless some years ago but that
really invented it didn't work out well
okay he six is a certainly good move him
in a bishop before his son is on his
agenda I I guess I can go a 3e but that
runs into Knight a5 stuff as well
this is not really all that grade my
bishop on edge for is not
not really great it's kind of out there
doesn't do much yeah again I was playing
a bit of offbeat here with Bishop to g5
but that is not really great it seems ok
so just cancel
Blackey now may take on c3 and give me a
somewhat backward pawn okay
I'm taking this to simplify matters a
little bit and if it takes yeah if we
take to the pawn I would have gotten the
c-4 square and here I think I'm gaining
a little bit of time because this bishop
will probably retreat to g6
I don't think he wants me to take it so
now a three yeah I think this is a
useful move
black can take on d2 and play Knight a5
but the threat of Knight be three years
I think not so relevant because I have
queen-to-be form a queen if a Knight f5
must be the idea otherwise it makes no
sense but I have this move I think him
maybe he didn't have it on the radar all
that much even though there is not b3
okay now I have brought I apologize that
is definitely true
huh that is actually very true I don't
have a good square here for my for my
work now
hmm I was only thinking about the
capture and then I'd be three but the
immediate night be three is just a lot
better
[Music]
huh that is not good at all okay so my
rook d1 there is Bishop c2 rook e1 he
will take and play ninety two so I will
lose an exchange in that way and drew
gage who looks utterly ridiculous
yeah still I don't or that is a terrible
move to play when the other moves just
lose in exchange so like for nothing
might lose the game but well what can
you do so
Bishop d1 now if I go Bishop to b5 the
knight would be attacked
he's got night c1 and then look a one
yeah maybe
you know that's really borderline it
could could be lost somehow
and I don't see it at the moment how I'm
losing but I could one key issue is I'm
playing without the bishop on h4 it's
just like standing there then there's
nothing absolutely nothing
Bishop c2 probably Bishop a4 is playable
let's see one look a one should be okay
now he's thinking for a while which is
not unreasonable because it looks like
that could be a kill
black is certainly better in many ways
some mecanim have charm speed up
he's falling behind on time a little bit
yeah that makes sense so I have moved
this don't have many good squares really
okay one will take it still sucks still
a really bad position on a slip again
due to my non bishop
when the upside is he's taking a lot of
time yeah
might be three now I have to I have to
leave the a foul
now how do we do this this one yeah for
Bishop you won if I get down now this is
helping
let's do this
now here now now it's night is a little
bit short of squares now it's not doing
this the best possible way No
um yeah doesn't really matter I'm piss
up
no maybe this
traded
that was actually not a good idea
shoot the bishop stays a terribly bad
piece really
see three I'm such a [ __ ] that was a
terrible decision really
so what totally totally terrible
[Music]
okay
I might be able to choose wrong him
somehow
and what it was is extraordinarily bad
technical play um could be could still
be a draw actually
maybe this I know I can do this
but still I was boots that was a really
bad game
oh my god
I was really I was bad and certainly
lost them okay now this was it's not an
opening idea you you should copy I guess
you know yeah I don't know I was just
improvising and you know so c3m it
really feels like after Queen to b6 that
black is already young grabbing the
initiative there maybe I should play
Queen b3 a plate this rather quickly not
really paying much attention at this
moment but it really looks uncomfortable
already if v is an interesting take on
the position here
the ideas that there is really very
substantial pressure here I have any
three so I'm not losing like on the spot
but it's it's pretty awkward just cancel
some and develop quickly yeah but it's
Bishop f5 is good yeah black is
definitely for choice he sings it should
be too should be for castles and I
honestly thought that here
I could be I could be close to repairing
things but it really is not the case if
I cannot play a3 and I cannot we saw
that then I'm in trouble because I mean
Black has the easy moves Eric c8 and so
on I'm playing without this Bishop it
just stares into nothingness and after a
three take take Knight a5 this is just
just awful
that's really awful what I overlooked
basically I mean I saw 95 but I just
didn't pay attention that he can do this
I was only thinking of taking like this
Andrew K 3 and here I'm more than fine
actually
but 93 is of course a lot stronger yeah
now we have to bite the bullet and play
okay - it's just awful but what what to
do rook c8 yeah the engine doesn't
display but should be five so it seems
to be blunder
yeah and a five is a refutation okay
Hey oh my god
and now you cannot even move this as
your queen gets trapped it's totally
totally in areas
oh my god yeah so a five was winning him
okay a night see one is also winning and
then a five I guess a five somehow was a
blind-spot job you know
a five is the kind of move that is just
very strong for concrete reasons it
looks ridiculous from a strategic point
of view giving wipe to be 5 square
somewhere which business there is
totally irrelevant of course yeah I can
you plate this and maybe maybe now I'm
ship d7 okay mm I mean this was still
very very awful but should be b1 oh we
should be oneness very effective
threatening mate and threatening the
rook
now this this was still bad but the
immediate loss was avoided and I think
here yeah
the next couple of moves I think there
should be also some improvement for
black because once I got this and this I
mean I'm still bad but now you know it's
just zero something we were on one point
whatever and handle a lot more now here
you should see 392 for not see form I'd
still would yeah and it is just a very
bad position and yeah okay here him he
plundered the denied by now and
reasonably confident that I could maybe
hold this
new mayor that is probably okay you look
at stuff like this I'm going to be okay
and after that I won the night but I did
not play well absolutely not
in particular here there was just no
reason at all to give up the pawn I mean
I was just after trains but like this is
strong or just cover it I was just
looking for trades and honestly this
this is a total lemon a total lemon I
mean I saw it quickly but it's just
super bad with rooks on the board
I went very easily actually I stopped a3
and just then start to convert but here
he's he has this idea to just go go over
here a3 and I cannot cover their pawn
reasonably I just cannot and I'm not
surprised that the engine gives black an
advantage I actually suspect that it is
winning yeah yeah if you give it a
little bit more calculation time then it
goes up it must be a win somehow so king
b5 is right it's clear so I have to
approach with the king I don't think
there's much room for improvement there
King here
king of form I just have to again have
to be quick with the King otherwise it's
pointless and I won't decide eeeh so I
was hoping that if he goes here when you
cannot really calculate with seconds on
the clock I was hoping this this so this
this this a3 cake cake and now King the
six could be could be okay or anything
could be okay king d6 he just goes here
and it makes no sense actually it's
interesting that the engine is not
giving a super clear evil here at
surprising
[Music]
I mean Black has a slight advantage is
kind of that that is not an email either
meaning should winning should be winning
for black may never be surprised if not
so like this this this and this is a
draw are you kidding me
really
give me more death that's a drawing
q4g five
to draw so he'll hear some f6
then this some miraculous escape yeah
with King he and I'm just in time okay
that's amazing and if he just like Waits
five is it ro g5
each six
take
he and probably a king of six how Kim
it's amazing it's exactly this way to
draw
No
oops no that's not right to go him and
here's just a draw hmm is it to draw
them
the engine gets black an advantage does
it does it see a win
you
that is this position hmm it's really a
remarkable that is the draw
so age five if black stops that with h6s
let's check this juice out or then I'm
even winning
if they
is crazy
yeah okay I try to fight my way through
here if six takes
yeah I'm quicker I'm just quicker g4 and
g5 remarkable
so this is a draw then
it's to draw them if it doesn't see
anything here it's a draw
I'm stunned that doesn't happen all that
often I mean that that you are that you
drawing upon ending up on down and it's
not like immediately obvious like you're
both sides promote and that's perpetual
or something
oh okay yeah okay in the game
[Music]
ah wait King is fine
what does the engine give them a bishop
bishop c3 a bishop serious cannot be
right yeah then there's a three king if
five
and I just thought deep enough I guess
or doesn't see something now I'm kind of
irritated here buy this buy this stock
fish no additives - for how does it give
- for king bee - Bishop before a3 no now
it I mean it is rather deep it is really
deep
whoo okay so in the game played f6 which
is perfectly reasonable especially if
you are like in in this blitz situation
it's perfectly reasonable that you play
this King III King b3 this this and now
I get I get to stop the pawn at least
but it should be a draw then I'm
absolutely willing to believe but this
is not a toy he has to go here to
actually ensure promotion
so if by the general a four a three
I have to stand made him crazy crazy
this is the draw that is crazy
yeah and this is a draw I have have
endless moves here I keep him stalemated
and
take take what was that No
g3 and there is just no breakthrough
yeah you cannot do this just I mean you
have to check it here this this this d2
King takes King bee to Queen Queen and
simply trading is enough this school and
I'm winning winning this of the rest
yeah so this is citron this is crazy
there's a remarkable ending it's a
remarkable ending in the Blitz game in
there is some some some study like
features I mean not like an ingenious
study or something but really great
interesting so ok to complete the whole
picture he went here and now he cannot
promote the pawn because it can only go
here and then thence then it's the end
so this should win simply because he
gets out of moves
ok GeForce gotcha firefight that wasn't
very intelligent it seems f4h for look
better indeed they do yeah how came he
don't have much time but it is it that's
really bad move okay so why is she 5
drawn let that just figure this out so
King did too
why is he not also running out of moves
here f5 King 3 a3 King to a 2
we should a 1f form
King b3 King a for ya I cannot I cannot
really
running out of moves him
nice Oscar I cannot just simply pick it
up because at the end he will grab this
so this was the game I got a four in
[Music]
hmm no name this
he's running he's running out of moves
down this this and this is almost a game
and then here I can always talk to on
him here and he has to go back
if you compare it
yeah I'm never getting I'm sorry
I'm never getting them I'm just never
getting to this configuration that I can
talk to on him the only thing he cannot
we can never go here but is still wrong
why is that
[Music]
this
kind of slow here
so this is winning
this is not
so how do I lose a move here this this
yeah yeah he has to go to a 4s the thing
you can never allow this in Bishop's III
me okay me but I was slow thinking
process okay I mean I have a coffee but
it's still early in the day and in the
in the game
we got them
and I'm winning this
some cool stuff in this ending I really
have to check this separately and check
some things okay guys thanks for
watching